foreign
welcome to the show
hi thank you guys so much for taking my
call thanks for calling how's it going
it's pretty good so I have a question
that I was wondering if you guys are
able to help me
um so I'm currently trying to figure out
what exactly would be the best option
for me at least in my situation
um my former job I had a 401k that I was
contributing to as well as with an
employer match and I'm no longer at that
job so since I'm no longer at that job I
was having a conversation with a
co-worker at my new job and they were
saying that since I no longer work there
I'm eligible to take that money out of
that 401k so I was wondering if that
would be a good idea for me to do to
help pay off my debt
you're I just who told you this and why
and do you trust them financially
because I wouldn't
have like a lot more use your experience
on me and they said you can just take
money from this 401k and do what you
want with it
um well they said that it's possible I
could take it out I know that it would
be taxed if I did take it out just
because I'm no longer at that job yeah
not only are you gonna have to pay your
income taxes on that there's also going
to be an early withdrawal penalty of 10
percent
right so not only is it a very expensive
way to get money you're also robbing the
future growth of that money in
retirement
okay so this is a terrible idea yeah
bottom line wouldn't do that so let's
look at other ideas that are better so
you have some debt you're looking to pay
off correct yes how much yes
um roughly around 43 000. okay what kind
of debt is it
um 2000 is about in a car loan
I'm alone
um around 8 000 credit cards and the
rest are my student loans okay
and what's your income
um I take home
quickly so probably monthly I take home
maybe about like 1400 to my take home
okay and what are you doing for work
um I work for like an I.T Staffing
Company I.T Staffing okay and what is
the current timeline for you to pay this
debt down if you just use your income
um if I just used my income I'm probably
in 2025 like early 2025 late 2024 really
yes what did you so you said your income
is 1400 a week
uh um or what's your annual income like
well every two weeks but annually I'm
projected to make um not including
bonuses probably around like 45. okay
that's where the math isn't adding up
for me as to how you'd pay this off in
under two years
I'm not sure this is what the calculator
said when I put in the numbers I do have
a side business as well so I do get a
little bit of income off of that so
sometimes like I sell things online and
then I have my own like I make candles
so I have a candle business on the side
as well awesome so if we ramped both of
those things up how much more could you
add to your yearly income
she went really hard doing that I would
say
probably if I worked really really hard
especially with the candles because
there's a lot of money to be made there
um I said I could probably add at least
maybe this year alone maybe at least
five to ten thousand awesome and are you
investing with your new employer
um not that I'm aware of no okay so I
would encourage you to pause all
investing and just focus on this debt
and make that your one priority how much
money do you have in the bank
um I do have my thousand dollar
emergency fund I do have maybe about 500
extra because I also planning on moving
out of the state
okay moving out of the states
yes out of the Florida moving out of
Florida moving to Maryland okay is that
a job
um yes for a job I currently stay with
family so I can't really like stay here
forever and he has kids so I kind of
need to think up in my next step so
you're gonna have to find a new job
um my job is in Maryland so I was more
than likely going to see if I could just
transfer okay awesome and do you want to
move to Maryland
um I do want to move out of Florida but
like Maryland just seemed like a nice
alternative I would just make sure like
as you think through that move
um cost of living in Maryland may be
quite a bit more than Florida so I would
just run some numbers on that because
you may want to wait a year or two until
this debt is tackled
um granted if you do want to move
especially if it's a raise then that
could be good but just also make sure to
factor in those extra things because you
said with family you got to move out but
you know perhaps you could find
somewhere in Florida on your own for the
time being
but I will say I I it's hard George
because I've been getting this question
quite a bit recently with the 401K
um option A lot of people are getting
tempted to pull it out and it is
tempting because you know with your
income you see that debt and it's like
man I could have this debt wiped out
quick it looks like a shortcut it looks
like a shortcut but but in the long run
especially when you factor in all the
growth you would lose it does not pay
off if I know it's not fun thinking
through you know paying this off and it
taking two years but in the long run
this will Roi so much more so Ellis
here's the math on this you have 43 000
in debt and let's say you're going to
pay this off in two years or less that
means you need to throw eighteen hundred
dollars total at the debt and you can do
this using the debt snowball method
which is smallest to largest regardless
of interest rate attack the smallest one
with everything you can throw at it pay
minimum payments on the rest and so if
you do that and you start bringing in
more income by selling stuff online
flipping stuff any money you can
scrounge up from the side hustles or
selling stuff you have laying around the
house uh obviously getting a raise maybe
even switching jobs that is going to
help you do this faster and then you can
get to the fully funded emergency fund
of three to six months that is your next
goal once we have the debt paid off and
you may want to sit down with a smart
faster Pro because you do have the 401K
and you've left jobs they can do a
rollover for you and figure out how to
invest that in the meantime yeah is this
a traditional 401k or is it a Roth
uh it should be a traditional 401K okay
so what you want to do is a direct
rollover to a traditional IRA that way
there are no penalties the you never see
the money it just goes straight into
another retirement account and then you
have options to invest way more than you
would have in your 401k
how does that sit with you
um
that's a good one and notice
that if I took it out there'd be like a
lot of penalties they were nice enough
to at least explain to me all the
penalties that I would have to say
um so the guy was like yeah do you want
to do it now I was just like um let me
feedback and I'll let me talk to some
professionals so who's who's the guy
like he's able to do this for you I'm
confused was it your employer no he was
just a co-worker he was just a co-worker
that was just talking oh okay all right
well hey I'm gonna gift you one year of
Financial Peace University and every
dollar to walk you through this process
the videos are going to be super
motivating watch all nine lessons start
that every dollar budget connect it to
your bank account start tracking the
transactions you're going to start to
feel the Steam and it's going to get
addictive you're going to go okay wait a
thousand on the debt this month how do
we put 1200 the next month and 1500 the
next month that's fun that's fun all
right well stay on the line Austin will
get you set up and I just love that she
heard that from the co-worker it sounds
tempting right it sounds like ooh like I
can have my debt wiped out but then she
had that gut check and went you know
what I'm gonna talk to somebody else
about this because I think right now
that we're in such a culture where you
know there's Tick Tock people everywhere
there's everybody reading Financial
articles there's so many things where
it's easy for a lot of people to feel I
feel like they know a thing or two about
money and it's like the more I've
listened and talked to some people it's
like the advice almost seems right but
then you're like wait a minute well it
always sounds good at face value because
right it feels like a shortcut the
problem with shortcuts is it doesn't
lead anywhere worth going to because you
end up further into debt or staying in
debt longer and so we're seeing a lot of
this right now Christina people turning
to helocs they're turning to home equity
loans they're turning to 401K loans 401K
early withdrawals these are all terrible
options because we're not actually
fixing the behavior that got us here all
we're doing is trying to pull it under
the rug and go and it's gone but it's
not because now we've created new
problems for ourselves right and it's
stealing from the future when you get in
some of those savings calculators and
you see what you're losing in compound
growth it's like man that's just it's
not worth it but it is so easy when your
problem is right in front of your face
and you're like I've got this debt and I
want it gone it's easy to want to take a
shortcut and it's like we want you to
keep that anger and that feeling of like
I want this gone immediately but do it
the right way if you feel like that's
your only option you don't have enough
options